who is fellows caelers this is tool
minute peppers the carona fire in the
previous up so we talked about suddenly
classification good agree we
have mss an input and who your computer
the figure old where is ie in in this
image
learning gary sometimes such as
convolutional neural adwords
sing along gerrit however we just found out
that i van dal der Wissel to excellent
in de stiel quite right to find out how
they got to make a decision that an
email updates that rocket
this is in lace restaurant and simple
technique that goals by then a bug of
words it works a bit like looking for
keywords in the document and by using
those
tryin to find out what the right things
about time of like the short cuts tools
like to take for mandatory reading
we already have those  just
now in mage and so one for pins
where we slice on the image embers
marquises and type score
to what is see in those snippets flappie
here's
black maud ver ok become the weekend
conclude that we have  balk over hier
net weight and you what you're saying
ahoy why do i need to die grass from
guide to back of gets my talk about
this all met het
wel les look at the advantages and
disadvantages en usa moment dfds of bug
of features
is  that this is quite easy to interpret
this it is an open book
exhaust the scores for war die
snippets
me know exactly how we this season is
been eats and disadvantage one what she is
that i is it works shredded ethics
north the bigger special relationships
in a  image and therefore everywhere in
must be 543 two neural network
right
well let's adam an experiment and see
this is a paper by the cm group is the
previous episodes at the university of
de bingo so parliament works the
following his left right to combine
downhill with more  al adwords but
slicing gave the image
intro a patches and then four then in
two neural network and ask it to
classify the
in this case duo network will do many
small classification pie of in  it
snippets instead of one big decision
for the full image
de peper discussions that the final
classification evaluates a muslim as
in cheek maps and more this way
who her hope think we get the
technique in which euro gets late must
x-play missed season
mars like  how big of words works for now
let's call this not worth
bij met en nou golda meir papers week is
there is all her vision surprising
expected it is true dat looking gets
more snippets of de image can lead to
misunderstandings
for instance this image contains de
soccer  ball met wen zooming into small
patches
it might seem like this is a cowboy hat
on top of this child
however what is aan expect it is that
easily get back net producer surprising
gracie miller i will perform of the
guard mol at work by  danie blaze met dit
is 12
this has ever alcohol er is plus [ __ ] we
de cool want this meer is already
networks and great and identifying
objects in scrambled images with jim and
sarnath
de rea  son for this is that the order of
de tailleband mm we now have better
reason why this is the case
disqualification en for many
small home in the pantyhose
it superpowers when it comes to
processing scramble thingies that there is
beautiful controversy
corollary that is  innovative lee means that some
results that show the superiority of die
het neuron networks over the good old
back of features just came from using the
superior met
but from careful fine-tuning
nato risotto summary zal
en zo is goed piece of research
challenges and underlying cause  some
sense and some times in this case just
to sanity
there will up to say about this topic and who
's foils crashed service
so take this and his error profile king
guy you this is wi-fi or further
discussion wheelie cool work my love at
this video has been reported by the book
by using a double you got to excellent
audio books free of charge and recommend
that you click the link in the video
discription
sign-up for free and c  heck out the book
super intelia's bonnie pass
samurai for you one ever you're stuck
in tref i hear fierce linden wood exact base
book earlier
and he said many of you follow
scholars inside you and god
if you haven't red make sure to sign  up
now because this book discusses how it
could be possible to image the
superintelligent ai en wat such an
ongoing being could be like you get this
book free of charge and you can counsel
at any time you can go wrong loop go
through the video description  and sign up
under the appropriate links
thai watching and for your generous
support to see you next time